there's not many things I don't like
about you but the smell is number one
we've been dating now for almost four
years we've been dating for five days we
met when we were 14 years old we met at
a restaurant a December camp a dating
app yes we had a mutual friend she hated
me and over a period of time she hated
me some listen she turned out to like me
so his natural central appearance your
natural scent is very woodsy bold tiny a
little tangy John smells like that's
like his smell it is very particular to
him what is this smell for cozy I
definitely think that I can guess his
smell and a lineup
all right there I think I got it
[Music]
yeah something kind of sweet I don't
know what he said very pleasant
are you moving away from me person he
smells like that oh I hope he smells
lucky took a shower today
good okay yeah I'm getting like musky
[Music]
doesn't smell familiar oh that's no I
enjoy okay you keep smelling like that
that smells gonna work Rico smells like
air water were yet this person is
odorless I think it was either okay not
you not to the one that smelled a little
bit or the last guy I'm confident but
it's number one the last guy was it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
almost at three but there was something
about two that just smelled like home I
rocked it I did exceptionally well I
almost got it right I knew I should have
went with my first instinct do you spray
with notes of Buchan
[Music]
it does smell like Cola one spray will
last the day it's like fresh and crispy
you give off I own a yacht
laying out on the beach with the Sun
I'll spray this on you and then we'll go
y'all shopping I smelled Miami sipping
on Margherita temperatures like 85 so it
has like a wax stamp very classy it's a
very sleek design body wash and spray
and a deodorant you might as well put
that oh right now
this is how much he uses every time I
definitely think I would have done
better if he was very much keep it
definitely bring it and you are a
top-notch man so it's for you babe I'm
waiting and we'd have definitely win